>>> TODAMAS ONE YEAR
DONANFOUT. JOHN'S CHURCH AT THEI
THE D.C. POLICE FINALLY
ADMITTING THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT .
YOU'LL RECALL THATYEAR POLICE C
WERA  FRONT
OF THE CHURCH THAT HAD BEEN T BY
CHEESE.
>> IT DIDN'TM TO O OF RITY WITH.
IT SEEMED TO BS WE'VE SAID
BE, AN OPPORTUNITY THEHI MANTEST
E.
A A INSISTED THAT NO ONE
PRESIDENT AND HITETH
IT ALL OVER AGAIN,LD YOU
GASSED AN
PROTESTERS TO CLEATHE PARK SO
THE PRESIDENT WOD HAVE A PHOTO
OP?
>> WASANULLETS.
NO RUBBER BULLETS WERE USED. T
>> THEY DIDN'T USE TEA
KE
MOST NEWS ISTH
FAKE.E AD BACKU
>> THERE WAS NEVER ANYGAS.
THEY SOME SMOKE
BO
ARMAGEDDON, REALLY?
TEAR GAS LIE IS PROF ALFWAY  F.
THAT.
TIM MURTAUGHE SPOKESMAN,
WO OSAORY ANTI, THWHE OF THE
PRESS CORP
THE NEF  ATTACK ON
PEACEFUL PROTESTER
EVIDT SUCH CIMTS OIT.
S PRETTYKABLE.
IT HURTS.NS.
UR EYES ANURE AN
NO-TEAR GAS ANGLE IS  COLLEN
WRONG.
ALEX WENT ON, S 25
MINUTES RE CURFE
THERE WAS NO OBVIOUS WARNING TO
PROTLEAVE.
AND THEN THERE WERE THE PICTURES
WHERE YOU CAE AFTERMATH
WHO WAS THERE WHID TS SSESNDER D
>> I COULD FEEN MY
EYES AND NOSE.
D F MY PREVIS EXPOSU
TO TEAR GARECOGNIZED TONS CONSNS
EET NEARM DeMARCO WATHSOTWEEN T
PARK POLICE.E USE OF FORCE THERE
DEEPLY DISTURBING.
PROTESTERS.BUT THD ISMPLETET RK.
G TO
DEFINITION OF TEAR GAS TO EIR OG
BL Y CAUSING IRRITATION HEYE MO
YEAR AFTER TRUMP ST OF ST. JOHNR
ACTIONS, THAT'S HO
ASTS BY
PR T ATTORNEYS
E CURFEWE OF
GHAOS CREAD
DEFENDANTS, DISCHARGE OF TEAR C
UNREASONABLE.
AND THE TO CFI TARGET SPECIFIC.
EAGAG
PEACEFUL CROWD INDISCRIMINATELY.
T THTIN THP CAMPAIGN KNEW IT
REPORTING.ORTED THE  LIE S
IT HASA YEANNALLY, AN ERT YOU
CAN'T JUSTSS.
TO QUOTE FORME
SPM RT
P QUOTE WHEN HE
YORK TIMESITD
PANTS ONTS